more than 50 conservative MPS have
signed an amendment to abolish mandatory
housing targets now that of course could
tear up Boris Johnson's Manifesto
commitments to build 300 000 new houses
a year to help ease the housing crisis
last year they managed not much more
than half of that with just over 175 000
new builds in England but we're joined
Now by Theresa Villas a concept of MP
behind the amendment good to have you on
the program so what's the idea for the
amendment Festival
the amendment is to return local control
over planning decisions
to local communities these targets I
think are based on 2014 out-of-date
population figures they're
disproportionately
um pushing for delivery in the crowded
Southeast and to meet those Targets in
the Southeast there's a danger that we
essentially risk making the same
mistakes as the 60s and 70s with
high-rise high-density blocks Greenfield
development all of which would be
damaging to our environment and the
quality of life of many people the
government's Now set to pull the votes
completely tomorrow do you see that as a
victory I think it is an important
Victory and I really welcome the
government's decision on that because
they were sending a clear signal that
they wanted to look at these issues
again and the secretary of state has
subsequently been out on the airway
saying he really understands our
concerns and he wants to to try and
provide some reassurance so I hope that
does happen and have you been talking to
ministers to get the reassurance that
you want oh actually again and again and
again over over a period of years and
and that will obviously continue because
I mean we can't continue as we are I and
many of my colleagues have felt like our
constituencies are under siege of course
we need new homes but they need to be
the right homes in the right places and
they need to be supported by appropriate
infrastructure so in your conversations
have you seen a shift more recently then
in the government's attitude on this do
you think
well in his public comments the
secretary of state has has repeatedly
said that you know things do have to
change and there needs to be a response
to these back bench concerns it remains
to be seen what that response will be I
hope but I hope we do see some serious
change because I I am Gravely concerned
about the impact on the environment of
these targets and how they're operating
at the moment so you've obviously got
concerns about the environment concerns
about constituencies like your own but I
just want to read to you from the last
Manifesto you know the Manifest that you
stood on we will continue our progress
towards our Target of 300 000 homes a
year by the mid-2020s this will see us
build at least a million more homes of
all 10 years over the next parliament in
the areas that really need them now you
know as I said an introduction you know
last year there's just over 175 000 new
houses built in England that's not much
more than half the target you've got to
do something about this haven't you well
removing mandatory targets won't mean
that house building grinds to a halt the
actually local councils
to actually do some of the introduction
the mandatory targets I mean we just
have to look for example at the
experience of local plans which are in
local neighborhood plans where you give
communities in a relatively small area
more control and power responsibility
over home building and in those
instances they've really stepped up
local decision making taking communities
with you is a way to deliver new homes
we also need to see homes being much
more Central to the government's
regeneration of of towns and cities
around the Midlands and the north they
can be a positive part of leveling up
whilst at the same time taking the
pressure off some of the hot spots
across the rest of the country
particularly the South and London come
on you can't really expect us to believe
that you know local residents can be
like yep let's have loads more homes in
our communities that's not how it works
you know in in many instances of course
local residents will accept new homes
but it's they have to be supported by
appropriate infrastructure and and it's
not um it's not acceptable where these
where these new homes cause significant
environmental damage we need to get a
better better balance and a fairer
distribution of new homes across
different parts of the country you know
there's so many young people who are
struggling to get in the housing ladder
rental prices are soaring what reason
are you giving those young people to
vote conservative
because the conservatives are the party
that could be trusted on the economy
because we're going to get taxis down
and yes because we're going to help more
people on the housing ladder we will
continue to deliver new homes that that
is absolutely the right thing to do and
removing mandatory top down targets is
is not going to stop that it just means
that we'll need to take communities with
us in terms of housing delivery so
housing is something which is done with
the consent of local communities not
done to them I just want to read you a
quote by Saturday Javed who's written in
today Sunday times he says he's dismayed
by your Amendment and he says it would
put meaningful policy into reverse we
risk creating a generation that turns
its back on the politicians who failed
them a generation that without any
capital of its own becomes resentful of
capitalism and capitalists has he got a
point uh I I disagree with with sagid's
approach I I think you know future
Generations won't thank us if we destroy
the environment in in the calls of
building new homes we can deliver new
homes we can do it in a sustainable way
with the consent of local communities
and uh I think the better way to do that
is to remove these top-down targets and
give more power agency and
responsibility to local communities at
the minute it feels like the attack line
that kirst armor is using again and
again on Rishi sunec is that he's weak
he says that pretty much every prime
minister's question if he's pulling
legislation because he can't get his own
back benches like yourself to support it
doesn't that just play into Labor's
hands
I I don't believe it does I think the
postponement of the vote that was due to
happen tomorrow is a sensible decision
it demonstrates a prime minister and
ministers who are willing to listen to
the concerns about benches made on
behalf of our constituents and just
finally well I've got you my Hancock is
going to be is in the final of I'm a
celebrity do you want to see him when
well I I think it would be great to be
one I have to say when it first started
I found it very difficult to watch but
he's done fantastically well I've
certainly been voting for him and I wish
him well with the final oh great I love
it then we've got a bit of an insight
into the who's voting for Matt Hancock
why did you find it difficult to watch
at the beginning
well I I mean I suppose it's a fairly
sort of excruciating sort of thing to
see people people go through buried
alive or gunsed or yeah made to eat
various parts of animals anatomies but
he's he showed incredible resilience and
bravery going through those those tasks
and people can can see him for the you
know the the engaging and you know
and and sort of a great human being that
he is okay thank you very much for being
on the program today Teresa Villas uh